what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving deep into the chaos once again
in order to explain what exactly just
happened in the seven deadly sins we got
to see Arthur showing some big sword
energy we learned more about the monster
cath [ __ ] and Merlin is still up to
some mysterious secret plan there is a
lot to talk about so let's jump into it
if you enjoy the seven deadly sins
content on this channel and you want to
support it please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications massive
thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons who make videos like this one
possible the number of people who have
been supporting us on patreon and here
on YouTube using the join function has
been growing every month thank you guys
so much I'll talk more about patreon at
the end of the video but now please be
warned that this video will contain
seven deadly sins manga spoilers we're
talking about the most recent
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned
chapter three three nine starts off with
Arthur lying underground and crying out
in pain in the aftermath of his right
arm being devoured by calf the sins
rushed to help Arthur and they are all
confused as to why cath would attack him
they were all under the impression that
cath loved Arthur and that the two of
them were friends and I think that the
rest of us were under that same
impression as well including Arthur the
Lady of the lake explains that cath is
after the power of chaos and that Arthur
is its target for that very reason
according to the Lady of the lake cath
in his true form is very different from
the cath we've come to know so that is
why the lady was not able to recognize
cath for who it really was
for some reason not only was casts
appearance different but its magic was
different as well
cats full name is cath [ __ ] and he is
the embodiment of the desire for an
obsession with the power of chaos if
you've seen my previous under licence
video then you will know who cath
[ __ ] is
a cat-like monster right out of
Arthurian legend whose mother is a great
white pig known as hanwen according to
the lady calf Pollock is known as the
Beast tyrant who had challenged chaos to
a fight because he wanted to become the
king of chaos himself according to
legend Kath Pollock lost his fight
against chaos and he was exiled as a
result but he committed so many evil
deeds in the land that he was exiled to
that he was eventually sealed away by
the goddess clan this connection to the
goddess clan is pretty interesting
if the goddesses had sealed Kath Pollock
away then how and why was he released I
assume he wasn't in the coffin of
eternal darkness since he doesn't seem
to have a direct connection to the demon
clan but it's hard to know for sure at
this point maybe the goddess has
released Kath for a specific reason
maybe the goddesses are trying to gain
the power of chaos so that they can use
it to bring back their physical forms
that would be interesting in my opinion
but it's totally possible that Kath just
found a way to unseal himself and this
has little to do with the goddesses the
specifics of Cath's being sealed away
and then being unsealed are still
unknown to us at this time as bond and
meliodas prepared to fight against cats
new monstrous form even though they have
no idea what the creature is actually
capable of Arthur calls on them to wait
and he forces himself up to his feet
despite his injuries Arthur tries to
reason with Kath and he tells the
monster to stop after all they were
friends this whole time and Kath had
even risked his own life to protect
Arthur but the beastly Kath explains
that he hung around Arthur and protected
him because he was waiting for the power
of chaos to awaken within Arthur so the
plan has always been to eventually
devour Arthur and take the power of
chaos from him Kath Pollock then creates
a massive vortex in an attempt to suck
in and devour everyone present including
Arthur Merlin uses her exterminate ray
in an attempt to stop the vortex but
this doesn't seem to have very much
effect as King points out the sins are
already exhausted from the fight with
the demon king so this is not
best time for them to have to fight an
overpowered monster with a power that
they don't even know or understand
standing firmly on his feet
Arthur asks cath one more question what
am I to you
cath Paula replies by saying food
Arthur is just a delicious meal for him
when he hears this
Arthur is relieved because this means
that he can strike down the beast
without any hesitation
Arthur is then able to summon his
legendary sword Excalibur out of the
vortex that cath [ __ ] created and as
kath attacks Arthur in an attempt to eat
him
Arthur manages to use the new and
improved Excalibur to cut right through
the monster cath is seemingly destroyed
just like that as the monster appears to
crumble to pieces in the face of
Excalibur and with that Arthur is
apparently victorious but right after
that Arthur collapses it looks like he
has been completely sapped of his energy
his decision to be the one who fights
kath although effective took a lot out
of him which makes sense when we
considered the extent of his injuries
Merlin rushes over to Arthur and
Elizabeth quickly says that they must
bring Arthur back to Leonys in order to
treat his wounds
however Merlin says that she has done
too much and she can no longer mix the
sins up with her selfish whims
Merlin then says thank you to Milly Otis
Elizabeth and everyone else before using
a spell to teleport everyone else away
from her and Arthur as her an Arthur
remain alone she says that this is how
it should be because she chose this path
herself
Merlin then refers to Arthur as her
master and she vows to protect him even
if it costs her her life the final page
according to some translations reads
without seeking for their understanding
and nor their help
the witch carries on a new sin van this
chapter was weird and it raises so many
questions what exactly is this new sin
that the witch is carrying is it
referring to something bad that she did
or is about to do or is this tried
tell us that Arthur will literally
become a new member of the seven deadly
sins and replace Eskin or on top of that
why's Marilyn calling Arthur her master
when she has been his mentor this whole
time and when he is so much younger and
less experienced than her
I guess Merlin might just be committed
to serving the king of chaos but if so
what exactly does she need to protect
Arthur from by the looks of it cath is
completely destroyed unless the monster
can regenerate or something along those
lines and we know that the demon king
has been defeated so who else could
possibly challenge the king of chaos the
obvious answer is of course the supreme
deity but she has been ignored for so
long and the story that talking about
her until we get some concrete
information about her seems like a waste
of time at this point
also if Kath has really been defeated by
just a single cut from Arthur's sword
then what was the point of this big calf
twist in the first place
why have Kath transform and attacked the
sins only to have the same creature
one-shotted in the very next chapter in
my previous seven deadly sins video I
speculated it Kath may have a bigger
role to play in all of this and that
perhaps Kath will somehow connected to
the goddesses and the supreme deity it
now seems that Kath is connected to the
goddesses in the sense that they were
the ones who had sealed it away and so
perhaps the goddesses were the ones who
decided to release Kath again when the
right time came but other than that I am
really not sure about Kats overall
relevance to the story as things stand
right now my suggestion that Kath may be
more important to the story than we
realized seems highly unlikely
other than being born from the mother of
chaos and being obsessed with obtaining
the power of chaos what was castes
purpose in the story at this point I'm
really not sure finally what is Merlin
really up to right now
she called Arthur her master and pledged
to protect him she also used magic to
get rid of all her friends and now she's
alone with Arthur and I guess the Lady
of the lake so what is she going to do
and what new sin is she carrying
Merlin might still have some crazy
sinful plan in mind a plan that may
involve her suck
facing her own life to protect Arthur
but we have very few details about what
she could be planning next all we know
is that it definitely involves the
incredible power of chaos and that the
target of Merlin's wrath might be the
supreme deity but again might is the key
word here it's clear that Merlin has
been hiding things from the sins and
that she is clearly up to something that
involves Arthur and the power of chaos
but we don't really have enough
information to speculate much further I
will say that I liked seeing the return
of Excalibur and at this point it looks
like Excalibur has finally become the
kind of legendary opie weapon that our
theory and legend builds it up to be I'm
looking forward to learning more about
the new Excalibur and seeing it in
action again but with that said I really
do wish that we had gotten more answers
in this latest chapter at this rate we
just keep getting more and more
unanswered questions and I'm betting
that a lot of you are getting pretty
anxious to get some frickin
answers just like I am oh and speaking
of questions how exactly does the Lady
of the lake fit into all of this and
what role is she going to play in the
rest of the story there is just so much
that is still a total mystery to us well
let me know what you guys think did you
enjoy Chapter 339 or did you find it as
cryptic as I did are you okay with the
way that things are going or are you
getting anxious to get more answers and
what is Merlyn really planning what is
she about to do next
feel free to share your feedback both
positive and negative down in the
comments below if you enjoyed the seven
deadly sins content on this channel and
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest news and updates and
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible with all the YouTube
problems lately patron support is more
important than ever so thank you guys so
much special thanks to all of our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings eldritch
very dolla beat Anatole Kazansky Alfa
deal on hell Cruz team Sparky 65 cricket
XP Rohan Kapoor Jessica Maloney and
Emperor otaku and I can't forget the
ones that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the
wanna tear patrons including in grata a
Lola nada makoto-kun the world Steelers
the school bus and Tyson Queenie know if
you enjoy our work and you feel that it
provides value to you please consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear on our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]